daniela blandón vamos a hablar entonces
de economía en este segundo bloque
directo américa el fondo monetario
racional se mostró pesimista frente a la
economía del mundo que está pasando
danielle así es raúl pues el organismo
redujo su proyección de crecimiento
mundial para 2022 y para 2023 y culpó a
la guerra en ucrania durante la asamblea
conjunta anual de primavera de este
organismo y el banco mundial que se
lleva a cabo en washington uno de los
mayores prestamistas mundiales que es el
fondo monetario dijo que este año el
crecimiento global podría ser del 3,6
por ciento y no del 4,4 por ciento que
pronosticaba en enero antes de que
comenzara este conflicto para 2023 la
perspectiva es del 36 por ciento un poco
menos que el 38 por ciento previsto hace
tres meses el organismo destaca que la
guerra se produjo justo cuando la
economía mundial comenzaba a sacudirse
de los efectos de la pandemia lo que ya
se notaba con el crecimiento del
producto interno bruto mundial que fue
del 61 por ciento el año pasado después
de un desplome gigante en el 2 así es ya
lo estábamos conversando y seguimos
hablando también un poco de la guerra
porque argentina pedía más impuestos a
quienes se benefician de esta guerra que
se está viviendo actualmente en ucrania
pues el presidente alberto fernández
anunció que se otorgarían bonos
extraordinarios a quienes devenguen
bajos ingresos en un contexto de alta
inflación originado también en la guerra
la idea es entregar a los trabajadores
informales e independientes 18 mil pesos
argentinos esto equivale a unos 158
dólares de hoy en dos cuotas y 12 mil
pesos adicionales o 106 dólares en una
sola cuota para los jubilados y como lo
va a financiar pues aunque el congreso
que finalmente tiene que aprobar la
propuesta del gobierno es establecer
impuestos extraordinarios a las empresas
que tengan ganancias de más de 9
millones de dólares al año y que se
hayan beneficiado económicamente de la
guerra en ucrania por ejemplo los
exportadores de grano que se han visto
favorecidos por los precios
excepcionales de los últimos semanas
vamos a estar trabajando convocando a
las fuerzas productivas laborales y
políticas de nuestra sociedad en la
construcción
justamente de un mecanismo que nos
permita poder capturar parte de la renta
inesperada que no es producto de
inversiones adicionales sino que es
producto del shock que implica la guerra
que hace que ciertos sectores de nuestra
economía tengan la posibilidad de hoy
tener una renta que es extraordinaria y
del sur desde argentina subimos hasta el
norte a méxico vamos a ver qué es lo que
está pasando con el gobierno desaparezca
está a punto de nacionalizar el litio al
claro y no es ley todavía hay que
aclararlo lo va a analizar apenas el
senado después de que la cámara de
diputados respaldará esta iniciativa la
nacionalización de las reservas de litio
lo que busca es que no haya concesiones
ni contratos en adelante y que esa
actividad la lidere directamente el
estado cual es la polémica pues que hay
proyectos en marcha de exploración
aunque el gobierno dijo que respetará
las concesiones previas la empresa de
capital chino llamada van canovaca
noralis yum que tiene una licencia en el
estado de sonora en lo que se considera
uno de los mayores yacimientos de
mineral en el mundo es una de ellas y
por qué tan importante el litio entonces
mire ese componente es muy importante en
la fabricación de baterías de autos
eléctricos y otros dispositivos como
computadores portátiles celulares entre
otros y ahora es más codiciado que nunca
y le voy a dar un ejemplo las ventas de
autos eléctricos marcaron un récord en
2021 con 48 millones de unidades más del
doble que en 2020 y lo hicieron a pesar
de que los precios de las materias
primas como el litio justamente para las
baterías se han disparado más del 50%
interanual en el primer trimestre se
estima que el solo costo de esta batería
puede subir el precio del vehículo hasta
en un 30% en algunos casos bastante
codiciados puede ser así es danny y
vamos nuevamente hasta el sur la cámara
diputado de chile rechazó el cuarto
retiro anticipado las pensiones pues
había dos propuestas sobre la mesa raúl
una de iniciativa legislativa y otra del
gobierno y ambas fueron rechazadas
la diferencia de edad que en el primer
caso se permitía un retiro sin
condiciones mientras que en el caso del
gobierno pues pretendían que los
recursos sólo fueran utilizados en
ciertos casos de extrema necesidad desde
que inició la pandemia se han permitido
tres ocasiones en el retiro de hasta el
10% de los ahorros que tienen los
ciudadanos en los fondos de pensiones
pero con esta ya van dos veces que se
descarta un cuarto retiro indicadores
económicos las acciones mundiales están
mixtas con el principal índice de hong
kong liderando pérdidas y a la espera
también de cómo reaccione el mercado a
las nuevas previsiones del fondo
monetario internacional en europa se ven
avances en londres en parís en avances
no perdidas en londres parís y fráncfort
al tiempo que los precios del petróleo
también retrocede danny gracias entonces
como siempre por toda la información
económica en directo américa nos vemos
mañana con más si pasamos ahora a los
deportes con un maridaje